>> Tucker: AS YOU’VE SEEN AN
INCREASEEXCRUCIATING DETAIL, NO
INSTITUTION HAS COME UNDER MORE
FEROCIOUS ATTACKS THAN LOCAL
POLICE DEPARTMENTS.
IN MINNEAPOLIS, POLICE BEING
ABOLISHED ENTIRELY.
IN LOS ANGELES AND NEW YORK,
FUNDING IS BEING SLASHED
DRAMATICALLY.
MONUMENTS TO THE POLICE ARE
BEING VANDALIZED OR RIPPED DOWN.
IN A CITY OF ATLANTA, OFFICER
GARRETT ROLFE FACES THE DEATH
PENALTY FOR SHOOTING A MAN
CALLED RAYSHARD BROOKS AFTER HE
STOLE HIS TASER AND FIRED AT
HIM.
SO WHAT ARE REPUBLICAN
OFFICEHOLDERS DOING IN THE FACE
OF THIS UNPRECEDENTED ATTACK?
NOT A LOT.
YOU HAVE STEPPED UP TO DEFEND
THE POLICE FROM TOTALLY BOGUS
ACCUSATIONS OF SYSTEMIC RACISM,
SOME ARE REPEATING THAT.
ONE REPUBLICAN HAS GONE FARTHER
THAN THAT.
AS WE TOLD YOU LAST WEEK,
SENATOR MIKE BROWN OF INDIANA
HAS ENTERED LEGISLATION TO MAKE
IT EASIER FOR LEFT-WING
ACTIVISTS TO SUE POLICE
OFFICERS.
WE MUST DO THIS, SENATOR BRAUN
EXPLAINED IN PART BECAUSE
RAYSHARD BROOKS’ DEATH WAS
EGREGIOUS.
>> I WANTED TO PUT A TEMPLATE
OUT THERE THAT PROTECTS
LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM FRIVOLOUS
LAWSUITS BUT HOLDS THE EGREGIOUS
DEPARTMENTS ACCOUNTABLE IN THESE
INSTANCES OF GEORGE FLOYD A
RAYSHARD BROOKS OVER BREONNA
TAYLOR.
>> Tucker: IN CASE YOU SUSPECT
WE SOMEHOW SELECTIVELY EDITED
THAT CLIP, HERE HE IS GOING ALL
THE WAY IN ENDORSING BLACK LIVES
MATTER.
>> DO YOU SUPPORT THE BLACK
LIVES MATTER MOVEMENT?
>> I SUPPORT THAT MOVEMENT
BECAUSE IT IS ADDRESSING IN AN
EQUITY THAT HAS NOT BEEN SOLVED
FROM A GRASSROOTS LEVEL.
>> Tucker: AFTER A SEGMENT ON
THURSDAY, ASKED TO COME ON THIS
SHOW TO DETAIL HIS POSITION AND
OF COURSE BE HAPPY TO HAVE HIM,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
BEFORE I ASK YOU ABOUT QUALIFIED
IMMUNITY AND YOUR ATTEMPTS TO
WATER IT DOWN, I WAS VERY
SURPRISED BY THAT ENDORSEMENT
THAT YOU GAVE ON CAMERA OF BLACK
LIVES MATTER, BLACK LIVES MATTER
HAS OF COURSE CALLED FOR THE
MURDER OF POLICE OFFICERS.
WHY DO YOU SUPPORT IT AND ARE
THERE ANY OTHER REVOLUTIONARY
MOVEMENTS THAT YOU SUPPORT?
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON IN
THE FIRST PLACE, I KNOW WHEN YOU
CAME OUT, AND I LIKE IT WHEN
SOMEBODY DOES CHALLENGE
ESPECIALLY SOMETHING LIKE THIS,
WHEN YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT
CHANGING SOMETHING THAT’S BEEN
AROUND FOR A WHILE AND I COME
FROM MAINSTREET.
YOUR VIEWERS ARE MY SUPPORTERS
AND I’VE GOT ONE OF THE MOST
CONSERVATIVE VOTING RECORDS.
THAT’S TRUE.
YOU’D HAVE TO CHECK WITH THEM
JUST LIKE I CHECK WITH THE
INDIANA STATE POLICE, INDIANA
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION, SPENT OVER
AN HOUR WITH THEM LAST WEEK TO
MAKE SURE I WASN’T OFF-BASE.
AND HERE’S.
>> Tucker: I’M CONFUSED,
REALLY QUICK.
YOU WERE IN YOUR SUPPORTIVE
BLACK LIVES MATTER, HAVE YOU
READ THEIR WEB SITE?
ARE YOU WHEN -- WHAT DO YOU
SUPPORT?
>> NOT AT ALL.
I SUPPORT ANYBODY THAT DOES HAVE
A GRIEVANCE TO BE ABLE TO ERR IT
AND THAT IS IT.
THAT DOESN’T MEAN ALL LIVES
DON’T MATTER, IT JUST MEANS THAT
IF YOU THINK A CERTAIN SECTOR OF
SOCIETY HAS A GRIEVANCE, IT
OUGHT TO BE THROUGH TRANSPARENCY
AND A WILLINGNESS TO DEBATE IT
AND GET IT OUT THERE.
I’M GOING TO ALWAYS GO ON THE
MERITS OF THE PARTICULAR CASE
AND GOING BACK TO WHAT I LEARNED
LAST WEEK, FIRST OF ALL,
LAW ENFORCEMENT IN INDIANA WAS
TALKING ABOUT ELIMINATING IT.
FOR DRASTICALLY MODIFYING IT.
THIS WAS TO DEFINE THAT SWEET
SPOT TO WHERE THEY SAID THEY ARE
BEING UNDULY STIGMATIZED BECAUSE
OF THESE EVENTS BECAUSE IN SOME
CASES, THEIR OWN AREN’T HELD
ACCOUNTABLE, AND WHEN THEY KNEW
THAT, THEY BASICALLY SAID WE
NEED TO BE IN THE DISCUSSION.
GOT WITH OBAMACARE REFUSING TO
DISCUSS IT TEN YEARS AGO.
>> Tucker: I’M SORRY, WE DO
SHOW TAPE REVIEW SAYING THAT WE
NEED TO PULL BACK ON THE NEED TO
MAKE IT EASIER TO SUE THE POLICE
BECAUSE OF THE EGREGIOUS
INCIDENTS LIKE THE DEATH OF
RAYSHARD BROOKS.
YOU SAID YOU WANTED TO SPEAK
ABOUT SPECIFICS.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT HE WAS
KILLED UNJUSTLY >> Melissa: TO
BELIEVE OFFICER ROLFE DESERVES
THE DEATH PENALTY, WHAT DID YOU
MEAN BY THAT?
>> I BELIEVE YOU OUGHT TO HAVE
THE ABILITY JUST LIKE WHEN
ANYONE CIVIL RIGHTS WOULD BE
VIOLATED THAT YOU’VE GOT ACCESS
TO DUE PROCESS TO HAVE YOUR CASE
HEARD.
>> Tucker: THEY DO HAVE THAT
RIGHT.
A QUALIFIED IMMUNITY HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH THAT CASE.
HE’S BEEN IN CHARGE AND THEY
HAVE THE RIGHT TO SUE HIM.
AS YOU KNOW SINCE YOU ARE
WRITING THE CHANGE TO THE LAW.
SO THAT’S IRRELEVANT.
I’M ASKING ABOUT THE CASE YOU
CITED.
DO YOU BELIEVE THE OFFICE ARE
NOW FACING THE DEATH PENALTY
DESERVES TO FACE THE DEATH
PENALTY AND IF YOU DON’T, TELL
US WHAT HE SHOULD HAVE DONE.
>> I THINK THAT WILL BE
DETERMINED BY THE COURTS.
>> Tucker: YOU CITED IT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF IT?
YOU’RE THE ONE WHO CALLED IT
EGREGIOUS, SO WHY DON’T YOU TELL
US WHAT OFFICER ROLFE SHOULD
HAVE DONE WHEN THIS MAN FIRED A
TASER AT HIM.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I THINK THAT YOU SHOULD HAVE
HAD THE JUDGMENT IN A TRAFFIC
STOP LIKE THAT.
YOU DON’T SHOOT SOMEBODY IN THE
BACK.
WE KEEP DOING THAT.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
I WANT YOU TO EXPLAIN.
I THINK IT’S FAIR.
YOU ARE AN OFFICE HOLDER.
I DON’T NORMALLY PRESS PEOPLE
LIKE THIS BUT IT’S NOT FAIR FOR
YOU TO FILIBUSTER WITHOUT
ANSWERING THE QUESTION WHICH IS
VERY SIMPLE.
THE OFFICER FACING THE DEATH
PENALTY HAD A GUY FIRE A WEAPON
AT HIM, WHAT SHOULD HE HAVE DONE
THEN?
>> PROBABLY NOT HAVE KILLED THE
MAN.
>> Tucker: WHAT SHOULD HE HAVE
DONE?
LET HIM GO?
>> DO YOU THINK HE WAS GOING TO
GET AWAY?
THEY WERE GOING TO FIND HIM.
>> Tucker: YOU TELL ME.
YOU’RE THE ONE JUDGING THE
OFFICER SO MAYBE YOU COULD
EXPLAIN WHY YOU’RE JUDGING HIM.
>> THAT’LL COME OUT IN THE COURT
PROCESS AND ALL I’M SAYING, LET
ME FINISH THIS, IF WE DON’T GET
BETTER AT IT FOR ALL OF US ON
MAIN STREET, DEMOCRATS ARE GOING
TO SPIN IT, CHUCK SCHUMER HAS
ALREADY DECIDED HE CAN MAKE A OF
THIS IN THE ELECTION AND WE WILL
END UP ON THE SHORT SIDE OF IT
AGAIN.
>> Tucker: WHO CONTROLS THE
SENATE?
I THOUGHT REPUBLICANS CONTROLLED
THE SENATE.
SO YOU’RE TAKING YOUR CUES FROM
CHUCK SCHUMER SAYING HE MIGHT
CRITICIZE ME AND THEREFORE I
HAVE TO PASS A LAW THAT MAKES IT
EASIER?
>> YOU KNOW YOU HAVE TO HAVE 60
VOTES IN THE SENATE TO GET
ANYTHING DONE.
YOU CAN CHECK MY RECORD, I STAND
ON IT AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
INDIANA THINGS AND SOME OF THESE
CASES, IT IS GIVING THEM A BAD
NAME AND BAD APPLES.
THERE OUGHT TO BE DUE PROCESS
THEREFORE THE VICTIMS.
>> Tucker: SO WHAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT GROUPS ARE
ENDORSING YOUR BILL?
>> NOT ENDORSING IT BUT THEY
SAID IT WAS A GOOD PLACE TO WORK
FROM.
>> Tucker: WHY AREN’T THEY
ENDORSING IT?
YOU’VE CITED THEM TWICE AS
SUPPORTERS OF THIS IDEA BUT
THEY’RE NOT ENDORSING YOUR BILL
SO THEY DON’T ACTUALLY SUPPORT
IT SO WHY ARE YOU BRINGING IT UP
AS EVIDENCE THAT IT’S A GOOD
IDEA?
>> THEY THINK IT’S A BETTER IDEA
TO BE IN THE DISCUSSION THEN TO
BE OUTSIDE OF IT.
>> Tucker: IF YOU CARE WHAT
THEY THINK, WHY DON’T YOU WRITE
SOMETHING THEY’LL ENDORSE?
>> THAT DOESN’T NECESSARILY MEAN
WE WON’T GET THERE.
THAT’S NOT GOING TO BE DONE
TODAY.
THE DEMOCRATS NOW THINK THEY CAN
WIN WITH THAT IN THE ELECTION,
AND THAT’S WHY WE NEED TO BE
ENGAGED NOW IN A WAY THAT WOULD
HAVE KEPT IT ON THE TABLE.
>> Tucker: SO YOU NEED TO
WRITE A BILL NOT BECAUSE COPS
ARE BURNING IT DOWN BUT BECAUSE
THE MOB IS, BUT YOU THINK THE
MORALLY CULPABLE PARTY AS THE
POLICE SO YOU’RE MAKING IT
EASIER FOR LEFT-WING GROUPS TO
SEE THEM.
AM I MISSING SOMETHING?
>> YOU ARE, TRYING TO PUT WORDS
IN MY MOUTH.
>> Tucker: I’M NOT.
>> I DON’T JUSTIFY ANY OF THE
LOOTING, ANY OF THE WRITING, AND
IF YOU DON’T ADDRESS THE
UNDERLYING ISSUE, YOU THINK IT’S
GOING TO FIX ITSELF ON ITS OWN?
>> Tucker: YOU THINK THE
UNDERLYING ISSUE IS RAYSHARD
BROOKS BEING SHOT?
YOU’RE TELLING ME THAT WHAT’S
HAPPENING NOW IS THE RESULT OF
POLICE BEHAVIOR, THE FAULT OF
THE POLICE?
THAT’S WHAT YOU’RE SAYING?
>> I’M SAYING WHAT THEY ARE
GETTING BY WITH ON THE OTHER
SIDE IS TRYING TO GENERALIZE AND
THEY WILL GET AWAY WITH IT IF WE
DECIDE TO DO NOTHING.
THAT’S JUST A GENERAL
DISAGREEMENT AND APPROACH.
>> Tucker: ARE YOU MAKING IT
EASIER FOR BUSINESS OWNERS TO
SUE THE MOB FOR BURNING THEIR
BUSINESSES DOWN?
HAVEN’T NOTICED THAT BILL COMING
OUT OF THE SENATE.
>> IF WE ARE NOT IN THE
DISCUSSION, WE ARE GOING TO BE
ON THE SIDELINES LIKE WE ARE ON
SO MANY ISSUES AS CONSERVATIVES
BECAUSE WE FAILED TO ENGAGE AND
THEY RUN CIRCLES AROUND US IN
THE END.
>> Tucker: YOU THINK YOU’RE
GOING TO KEEP THE SENATE IN THE
FALL ON THIS PLATFORM?
>> I THINK WE ARE GOING TO KEEP
THE SENATE IF WE AT LEAST ARE
WILLING TO ENGAGE IN ISSUES THAT
ARE IMPORTANT TO THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC AND THAT WE DON’T ALWAYS
STAND ON THE SIDELINES UNTIL
IT’S TOO LATE.
IT’S MORE ABOUT WHEN YOU GET
INVOLVED IN THE ISSUES.
>> Tucker: I DON’T THINK THE
PUBLIC SUPPORTS YOU AT ALL ON
THIS.
>> I THINK LAW ENFORCEMENT KNOWS
THEY NEED TO HAVE A BETTER
SYSTEM THAN WHAT THEY’VE GOT NOW
BECAUSE IT IS STIGMATIZING THEM